[Musique]
bonsoir des amis cette semaine beaucoup
de courrier et je suis particulièrement
fier de vous car la plupart de vos
lettres me pose une question que je
considère comme capitale comment
résorber les foyers d'infection que sont
dans les maisons les moquettes et les
bibliothèques les moquettes à cause des
germes rapporté de l'extérieur par des
semelles pas toujours bien essayé sur le
paillasson de l'entrée les bibliothèques
à cause de cette manie qu'ont les gens
de mettre dans les livres des choses ni
souhaitable ni glorieuse tels que crache
à crottes de nez vieux pansements etc
alors bien sûr vous avez tout essayé les
bunds les produits aseptisant le
récurage alou de javel rien n'y fait les
germes reste et la maladie continue de
proliférer et d'entrer dans votre maison
n'y at il rien à faire si bien sûr il
nous reste le vieux truc du roquefort
comme vous le savez le roquefort
contient une moisissure qui est
l'ancêtre de la pénicilline
c'est à dire un antibiotique très
efficace utilisée depuis longtemps en
auvergne pour soigner les plaies des
vaches et des vulcanologues
alors il vous suffit d'étaler ce
désinfectant puissant et naturel sous
chacune de vos chaussures comme ceux ci
ont 50 grammes environ pour un
appartement de 50 à 80 mètres carrés au
delà de 100 mètres carrés plus de 80
grammes une fois ceci fait vous prenez
le reste du roquefort et vous le malaxer
doucement entre vos mains pour vous en
faire comme une sorte de paires de gants
et voilà le tour est joué vous pouvez
normalement dans votre appartement
en feuilletant de temps en temps un
livre le roquefort s'occupe de tout fait
ce petit truc deux fois par jour et si
dans un mois il reste encore un micro
sur votre moquette ou dans votre
bibliothèque
vous pourrez dire tant palin est une
coquine
allez vive l'hygiène et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]